Director:
Ready?
Action!
♪♪
(Aaah)
With sci-fi you can get lost in
studio sets
♪♪
Rory Cheyne:
We wanted to open up the scope
and get into locations that were
Rory Cheyne:
cinematic and beautiful.
♪♪
We went to over a half dozen
countries.
♪♪
Rory Cheyne:
We went to Iceland,
The Canary Islands,
♪♪
Rory Cheyne:
Malta, and Ireland.
♪♪
Rory Cheyne:
Where we built a lot of really
massive practical sets.
There were so many elements that
needed to work,
Rory Cheyne:
to create these different
worlds.
♪♪
This show is massive.
Lee Pace:
There's an insane size to this
world,
Lee Pace:
including a planet that's
completely underwater.
Director:
Going down...
Ready...
Director:
And action.
♪♪
Ian Hunter:
While other shows may rely on
lots of green screens
Ina Hunter:
and virtual sets, etc.
Foundation is actually using
physical sets.
♪♪
Ian Hunter:
And that combined with shooting
on locations, will
Ian Hunter:
give the audience a real
visceral feel that they're in a world
Ian Hunter:
that's been built from the
ground up.
♪♪
The story goes to so many
different places.
Alfred Enoch:
It shows us so many different
locations.
♪♪
It takes more power to build
than to burn.
♪♪
And I want to build, Hari.
Rory Cheyne:
It was a challenge to sort of
figure out
how are you going to build
things.
♪♪
Rory Cheyne:
Like Trantor is so many
layers deep.
And then, each layer would be a
different architectural style.
♪♪
And Synnax, being mainly a
water-world.
Everything sort of built on
stilts.
Rory Cheyne:
That was a definite challenge.
Every detail has to be thought
about and designed based on what each planet was.
♪♪
Russel Rothberg:
Our sets have gone over the top
and are amazing.
♪♪
Definitely make everybody feel
like you're in that world.
♪♪
Leah Harvey:
Going on those sets was awe
inspiring.
♪♪
They are just made so well.
It was amazing to be in one of
those sets and feel like you're
at home.
I think we made something
special.
David S. Goyer:
And we're all really excited for
the audience to experience it.
♪♪